muster vm kam 2018 als flüchtlinge aus
afghanistan nach deutschland jetzt ist
der tod der 24 jährige verlor sein leben
nicht auf der gefährlichen flucht
sondern im alltag bei einer fahrt mit
der s bahn in schäftlarn bei münchen
krachen am montag um 16 35 2 s bahnen
der linie 7 in einander muster verein
wird bei dem unglück getötet 18 weitere
menschen werden zum teil schwer verletzt
insgesamt sollen etwa 95 personen in den
zügen gewesen sein darunter viele
pendler und schulkinder
die rettungskräfte sind bis in die nacht
im großeinsatz der hohe bahndamm auf dem
die gleise liegen erschwert die
rettungsarbeiten etwa 800 polizisten
feuerwehrleute und sanitäter sind im
einsatz das thw arbeitet die ganze nacht
durch nach bild informationen gehen die
ermittler davon aus dass einer der
lokführer trotz rotem haltesignal
losgefahren sein soll danach soll noch
ein folgefehler passiert sein der fahrer
soll offenbar nach einer notbremsung
ohne rücksprache losgefahren sein eine
der beiden s-bahnen hatte laut polizei
zehn minuten verspätung in die fern dass
eine rolle spielte muss nun untersucht
werden
bayerns innenminister joachim herrmann
sagt zu bild für ein technisches problem
gibt es derzeit keinerlei anzeichen
inwieweit menschliches versagen in frage
komme werde jetzt überprüft